bill Orem did a great job in summing all
of this up not just yesterday last night
but the entire season he's a the Lakers
writer for the athletic bill what the
hell happened last night this is
sounding and I mean just to kind of give
you a sense of how this went down Luke
Walton concluded his pregame media
availability which you know every game
at 5:45 p.m. in Los Angeles they talked
for 10 or 15 minutes and everybody kind
of assumed this was the last time so
there was kind of a somber tone from
Luke and Magic Johnson was kind of
lingering and he comes over and says and
kind of jokes to the PR person when do I
get to go and then he kind of takes a
beat and goes now I'm gonna go and he
holds out his hand she tries to stop him
and he gets behind the podium and says
he's quitting it was absolutely surreal
and unlike anything I've ever seen
take him through the pieces of this it's
something we're gonna probably be doing
for a long time but you know the fact
that you didn't talk to Jeannie buzz
beforehand and said basically they
thought it would be too emotional and he
thought that you know she would talk it
out of it you know once he put himself
on the record in front of the media you
know on in front of all those cameras
that really was no backing out so he
talked for 40 minutes tried to leave
stopped and talked for another 20
minutes and then said he was gonna go
try to try to go find Jeannie and talk
to her it was unlike anything I've ever
seen and probably will ever see again
especially when you consider the the
figure we're talking about here the
stature that Magic Johnson has in Los
Angeles with the Lakers the job he was
hired to do the job he has done you know
I think there's a lot of a lot to hold
on to if you're if you want to criticize
the job Magic Johnson and Rob Kalinka
have done but the bottom line is they
did emerge with LeBron James he's under
contract with three more years that is a
pretty decent starting block but now
he'll be back to the drawing board for
the Lakers who really are now you know
kind of in this in III view it kind of
as a chance for genie bus to kind of get
it right this time after after kind of
reaching for what was the comfortable
choice in magic last time but I really a
pree staggering moment but you have the
Lakers they whiffed on free agents here
and I always wondered was magic the
right guy because this was about Magic
Johnson and his personality his
competitiveness and it couldn't help
himself he was like we're getting Paul
George you know like you're not allowed
to say that
and then we're trading for Anthony Davis
no no you can't do that right now
it felt like he he every loss was his
loss instead of it being hey we're just
gonna figure this out this is all about
just understanding who we have and and
you know players who are gonna be in it
for the long haul or not and then we can
assess this when the season is over I I
was preaching that the entire season and
then all of a sudden it felt like they
panicked and they go you know what we're
not gonna make plans
let's get Anthony Davis in here and then
all of a sudden you know you got Luke
Waltons job in jeopardy then you got all
the injuries here if it could go wrong
it did go wrong amazing yeah and I think
I think you're right without the
personality as well I mean you go back
to last summer there was that that
lengthy summer league interview where he
basically laid out his vision for why II
thought the team's put together
correctly with you know with ball
handlers and and and going against
shooters and there was kind of an
incredible I thought hubris with the way
that the team was constructed despite
everyone kind of raising their hands
like hey wait a minute you don't have
shooters around LeBron James you're
you're you're bucking the convention
that has got into eight straight finals
are you sure you know what you're doing
and then during the World Series he's on
the world series broadcast and says yeah
yeah it's like I love bran James this
summer you know what next time I'm gonna
get another free agent I'm gonna get
another superstar and you just don't
hear that and there was you know you
know there was a video that was
circulating online a couple weeks ago in
contrast of the way Magic Johnson was
talking versus the way Jerry West talks
um and and the way you know Jerry West
would say you know you don't talk about
how great you are you talking you know
at the job that you're talking you know
I was never comfortable in the spotlight
and then you can trash that with the way
magic behaves and it's it's it's just
it's just the way he is he is wired
which was rate for a player and maybe
it's rate for his businesses that had
always struck a very
strange note coming from the big chair
of a basketball team particularly one
that wasn't winning and so you know the
Lakers gonna hit reset here and as it
the change to Luke Walton day and I
think I think I think I think you felt
like you've got a little bit of a raw
deal this season or were set to get a
raw deal yeah it sure sounds like magic
is his stepping down so Jeannie can keep
her guy in place which I'm not wait and
I've been a supporter of Luke Walton as
well I'm not entirely sure that's great
business either
thank you makes the you have to make the
right business decision and stand by it
and move forward you can't you can't
quit so you're your best friend doesn't
have to fire somebody she loves if the
if the if the feeling in the building is
that you need to make a replacement it's
it's just a very it's a very strange
message situation I mean it's it's 7
a.m. in LA I think we kind of thought
that we'd be getting a Luke Walton
announcement around now before the
before this magic thing happened and now
nobody knows it's going to happen
whether you're moving forward with him
whether bill do you think the vision
Luke thought he was being fired last
night like he yes okay yes it's amazing
really it and and I if I said you could
interview any of the principal's here
like you can go LeBron you can do magic
Genie who would you want to have a sit
down one-on-one with today
Jeannie bus because it is this story
touches all of the you know all of it
touches every nerve I mean it is
emotional it is in his family it is you
know I mean I mean Dan it's kind of
Shakespearean right I mean does she feel
betrayed by magic not talking to her
before he goes in front of the cameras
is she does she feel let down that he
you know only gave this two years I mean
this has to be an extremely emotional
day an extremely emotional chapter for
her I mean but you when you understand
kind of what the Lakers mean to her not
just as as her business but the family
business what it meant to her to be
entrusted with the Lakers by her father
before he passed away in 2013 and what
she believed it would have meant for him
to reach into the Dorgan
past higher Magic Johnson to save the
team only for him to say very abruptly
two years in this isn't for me I can't
be me anymore
and just walk away so that I think it's
probably the most compelling aspect of
this then the other part is what the
hell is the team gonna do you have you
have a massive summer you have a 34 year
old LeBron James and you have you have
calf space but no real great indications
that any of the top players in free
agency are going to want to take that
money so how do you how do you stabilize
this franchise in a matter of frankly
weeks to make this a more appealing
destination than it wasn't Magic Johnson
was here and so she when she had the
opportunity to hire magic or when she
had the opportunity to fire her brother
and Mitch Kupchak and reshape the front
office and her vision she did something
that was easy she hired the people who
were closest to her she hired magic
Johnson she hired Kobe Bryant's agents
and and I don't think that has gone very
well and so now you know I think she
probably has to take a different tack
which is figure out who the best person
in the NBA is and how she can go get
them there is no salary cap limitation
on executives go figure out who is the
very very best person you can get not a
person with whom you have the best
relationship work or or think you can
trust right off the bat you can develop
a relationship with good people bring
back Jerry glass and be like it I mean I
listened and that is eight age being the
only factor and possibly the fact that I
think Jerry West might have turned
turned the page himself and is relishing
the role of spoiler in Los Angeles that
that aside I think that's great
otherwise you go down the list RC Buford
in San Antonio Sam Presti in Oklahoma
City Bob Myers in Oakland
Pat Riley people do move on in their
careers and I know we identify those
people so much with those franchises Wow
but there is no excuse for Jeannie buzz
not to be calling those people and
saying ten million dollars you want to
run the Lakers it's not it's not that
hard and if they say
no than you then you keep moving analyst
I want to I'm gonna play something that
magic said I don't know if anybody
followed up on this magic was talking
about the whispers and the backstabbing
this is what he said yesterday what I
didn't like is the backstabbing and the
whisper and I don't like that you know I
don't like a lot of things that went on
that didn't have to go on and so I hope
that after tomorrow
the Lakers can head in the right
direction which we are what is he
talking about
who's doing the backstabbing in the
whispering yeah he was asked about that
and and he did he said that it was not
necessarily the Lakers but just
basketball in general but two things I
think I think the Anthony Davis
situation was was a pretty key factor
here where he felt like in good faith
he's tried to make it make a big time
move for the Lakers and there was so
much talk there was so much information
out there about it it made them very it
made it very difficult for them to
operate on that deal to I'm not sure
what the state of the relationship
between Magic Johnson and Rob malinka
was by the time magic made this decision
he was asked directly if he thought Rob
palinka was the right it was the right
general manager for the job and he said
that's a that's a question that's a
question for Jeanie buss you know then
he alluded to maybe some baggage that
Rob pálinka has around the league in
terms of his reputation and says he
hears it from agents and then said that
you know he did say that they always
worked well together but there was
certainly not a decision for him and I
thought if that if he if there was a
strong bond there magic had an
opportunity to give give him a strong
endorsement on the way out the door and
in wasn't the other part of it is people
around the league were often and I heard
it Dan you probably did too there was a
certain degree of cheerleading about you
know Magic Smith steps he had not done
this job before he is a massive
personality in many ways he couldn't
help himself you know he got the Lakers
find a couple of times or
the league that was that was cheered in
kind of a diabolical sense and so you
know when you had any time magic said
something that could be viewed as
tampering you had people you know
scurrying to the league office trying to
get you know get it in front of them and
so you know he was upset about the Ben
Simmons situation where Ben Simmons
called the Lakers and says hey I'd love
to work with you you played the position
the way I play the position better than
anybody else that ever has can you can
you mentored me and magics and magic
version of the story and for the same
team the Sixers as he called
Philadelphia and said the only way I'll
do this is if the league signs off on it
and then magic shares that story in
Philadelphia and then the wagons kind of
circle and it becomes it becomes it
becomes oh did he tamper with Ben
Simmons well and I stand and listening
to him yesterday he spent some time
talking about that situation and it
seems like it wounded him quite a bit as
well good stuff bill I I didn't know if
you had your article prepared you
probably had your article prepared of
let's sum up the season and Luke Walton
being fired and what's gonna happen in
the offseason next thing you know Magic
Johnson come on down and at the
impromptu press conference what a crazy
crazy day crazy it's great it's the
craziest thing I've ever done you did a
great job with it summing it up Bill and
thanks for joining us this season we
appreciate your time my pleasure
take care that's a bill arm he covers
the Lakers for the athletic four more
Dan Patrick show tune in to audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app